[Applause]
first of all gentlemen we talked about
the division last week with a great
little chinwag about how that games
turning out and mm-hmm and the the beta
which is which is starting imminently as
well but an interesting thing happened
went to the statistics meeting on Monday
morning as we do here at GameSpot and
for some reason views on Ghost Recon
wildlands had just like spiked last week
it got us asking the question was the
gameplay that we were sort of hoping for
for the division two sort of this this
partying up open-world sprawling sort of
you know find your own adventure
experience was that actually more of
what's going on in Ghost Recon wildlands
then in the division so we saw Wyland's
in at e3 last year I'm kind of just
interested in your guys perspective on
what Wyland's is because a lot of this
has to do with like perception like what
is the game Peter to you what do you
think goals Ghost Recon wildlands is and
what do you think the division is is it
hard for you to like devise which is
which because both Ubisoft games were
third-person shooters like what in your
head gameplay wise how do they seem
different at this stage except it's hard
for me to offer too much because I
haven't really thought about that came a
lot since he's right but reading a bit
about it before the show this morning I
mean it sounds like it's a much more
it's a game that focuses on the tactical
aspect of teamwork and you know in
solving an issue and from what I
understand about the division that's not
so much the case like there obviously is
some tactical considerations at hand but
it's also I don't know how to
characterize it but it sounds like there
is maybe more substance to the tactical
side of a game right like yeah because
did well we've sort of seen from the
division since they've been showing a
lot of gameplay is that it's quite it's
quite wave based it seems like it's a
colour shooter yeah yeah and we're
looking at wild lines here which is a
game set in Bolivia you were sort of a
set of us undercover agents as it goes
tend to be we're going in to kill a
bunch of cartels and Ubisoft Paras are
making this who did the old generation
versions of Ghost Recon Advanced
Warfighter I think that was around the
same time that they acquired Red Storm
who made like that the proper growl
experiences but they worked on that
sort of stuff Red Storm aren't involved
in this they're actually working with
Ubisoft massive on the division and but
yeah as we're seeing from the gameplay
here it seems to be and you have to be
super careful here because this is all
pre you know this isn't this is
representative of the final product
which has gotten Ubisoft into trouble
watchdogs and you could say the division
sort of feels a little bit different as
well but what we have learned from it is
that you can go in all guns blazing you
can use sniper rifles you can use
stealth you level up your character
there's an element of customization and
there's stuff like friendly or hostile
and NPC's in the world you can get into
conversations with and apparently that's
going to like change your stake within
the wider world and and then the other
thing and this is sort of I feel like a
lot of games are trying to throw their
hat in on the co-op side of things and
then there are folks like me who are
loners you prefer to play games on my
own like I love falling into which your
meta solid they're games that you play
on your own this game you can play on
your own the division apparent you can
also plan your own but all we have
received in these games when they're
showing them off and we should've saw
with violence when they showed a d3 and
we've seen it with every division piece
of gameplay as well is its co-op
experiences yeah why do you think that
is why are you interested in co-op games
does that turn you off or does it
actually make it more interesting
because I guess there's big money games
like destiny right yes not my preferred
way to play
speaking of co-op it's I also prefer
single-player experiences but I really
do like when things can take co-op and
make it something special like left 4
dead or you know like I like Destiny's
co-op features but that's what the thing
about wildlands seems like I I'm hoping
it's what pizza it's more of the
tactical side of things you can go and
you know the trailer showed going in
with the Jeep and everybody just firing
off rounds and then the stealthy one was
kind of just having a sniper train on
the main guy they're trying to extract
and I'm going in stealthily but what I
think they might end up going for and
what it appears they're gonna go for is
more of a cooperative third-person Far
Cry right has Far Cry itself the way
they described the open metal world of
wild land just kind of more they said
there would be like outposts from what I
believe like this might have changed in
c3 but it'd be more you know like kind
of commanding certain parts of the map
and then teaming up with people and then
kind of you know clearing it out and
then finding new missions around the
world yeah I mean that sounds like
Ubisoft the form in there right sounds
like the structure that tried to tackle
it
yeah and I'm hoping they go with a pizza
because that was the main draw of Ghost
Recon games amazed I really like the
tactical side of things the coop really
worked out with those I actually really
liked Future Soldier yeah my favorite
thing but it was I thought they nailed
like especially in the campaign the
co-op campaign they nailed that kind of
teamwork so I hope that's what they go
for as opposed to the division which
seems you know RPG focused more of it
seems like white people are disappointed
as well a little bit is because they
thought that the division was going to
be a little bit more nuanced that way
but it seems like it's a just a Carver
shooter like a basic copper shooter the
thing that got me excited about the
division was the setting you know I mean
the fright it's in New York City it's
winter I love snow a lot of people have
snow and it was dealing with an outbreak
that it sort of caused this hysteria but
when you're describing like the laundry
list of features that they're going for
with wildlands I kept thinking to myself
like I like you could apply that list to
so many games where I passed five years
and maybe just take one feature out and
switch it with another I I just I can't
get really excited about these games and
maybe that's just me because it's not
really my thing it's not my taste but I
just I don't know like the division
seems to offer so much more in terms of
an interesting world than something mmm
like and like wild lands I mean is is
the the functional gameplay aspect of it
the little things it's bringing to the
table that interesting to get back into
experience that on the surface level to
me seems so predictable and like other
games like what is really
differentiating this is it just that
it's new and that they add in one other
feature that may be the last game like
it didn't have is that it or is it that
it's a co-op experience I mean it was
for the crew right like that was
basically a driving game like so many
other driver games I know right yeah
like I I it tried something at least at
the map site but like that's what it was
right it was it was open-world yeah and
it was co-op
yeah and that was basically and you can
actually say the same thing about farcry
4 farcry 4 also big open worlds bases
all that stuff like that's what Far Cry
3 was far cry 4 also had like did I I
played crap at a far cry 4 did any V do
you co-op in that game at all yeah you
didn't do you'd give it a go yeah
because then you could do like the what
they call the vertibirds or whatever
like resistance yeah I don't know you
could use those yeah and then a launch
yeah yeah I'm getting everything mixed
up now you can do like the person one
person the grenade launcher going over
the base but those were like the
cordoned-off instances where you do
co-op right you couldn't do that in the
hole could you good there was like a
certain actual what's his like Huck his
missions were all right okay yeah yeah
so mark right three had a co-op mode
which was instance right that was more
of like linear shooter but yeah far cry
4
you know incorporated it pretty well
because that's I know for a while that's
what I was hoping for from a game was to
have open-world co-op where it wasn't
like sectioned off into its own thing
and Far Cry did that well but I don't
know that it's as enticing as it used to
be I'm really interested to hear what
folks have to think about this actually
if there if there's one or the other
that the kind of looking forward to
while I sort of throw that out there can
you release both these games the same
year because they seem like they're
doing similar even if like Peter what
you're saying was the contemporary
setting of the division was definitely
something does sets it apart from other
games is probably one of the most
notable differences and the new Ghost
Recon game also said in sort of
contemporary times it's not future like
Future Soldier right but it's set you
know in a sort of the tropical you know
Bolivia it's you know it's it's
interesting in its own way as well looks
different yeah can you release these two
games in the same year considering
they're both essentially third-person
co-op shooters coming out of the same
company like different studios but you
know it's not all that different but
they the themes the thematic things that
sort of define the world might speak to
a certain demographic you know where the
Ghost Recon is sort of going for that
military feel so people who actually
write that stuff will say yeah the
division fine but military [ __ ] that's
where I'm at like it's more legit yeah I
mean I feel like with with the division
it's sort of a wider gamut of who can
get into it because it is more like a
slice of life you know in this sort of
fantastical scenario versus a military
covert op and Bolivia you know I think
that really speaks to a certain type of
person like I I could give a [ __ ] about
what guns they're using like oh yeah
they actually use that right some people
do and that's cool for them but I don't
think they're gonna be the same people
who fawn over the division just because
the base gameplay may have it like you
think we identify with a lot of games
because of the world they present us in
the story they tell us
whether it's overt or just suggested and
those games both tell very different
stories overall so I think it's okay
III don't know that it's going to you
know write or die based on whether the
gameplay is similar different than
another game right and a lot of people
in the chat saying the same thing sparks
V red animator wild lines the lights of
spring of 2017
oh sure I mean we haven't heard about
the game since e3 like knowing Ubisoft
and how they tend to market these things
like that says something you know I mean
even if it's just that they can't afford
to maybe back to your point they can't
afford to you know
confuse the market with too much
advertising around different games or
too much different you know preview
events mmm not so much the games are
competing because they're in the same
similar genre but because it's just we
only have the audience only has time for
so many games yeah and we're like
looking at this very much as a snapshot
of what's you know what we know right
now at the end of January 2016 like this
conversation a month ago would have been
so different this conversation six
months ago to been different so I guess
last question on this I kind of want to
gauge interest in your guys if you had
to pick one of these games right now
because this is kind of something I want
to revisit maybe in the future and which
one is are you more interested in and
for what reason Mike first of all oh
yeah ever since the e3 last year I've
been really interested in wildlands I
think that'd have to be my pick although
we don't know a ton about it but if they
do what they appeared to do in e3 with
that tactical bent and that really more
confined like four-person kind of
gameplay as opposed to you know the
division which teams more MMO ish I
definitely pick wildlands
well based off beat for the division for
the reasons I mentioned earlier I like
the setting and you know the themes in
the story but I also like kind of the
openness where people can cooperate and
turn on each other if they if they want
like I think that'll create some
interesting dynamics when it comes to
you know a group trying to succeed or
survive and hopefully we won't have to
pick from these games hopefully both
will come out with a little bit of space
around them and they'll both be
interesting in their own ways but right
now if I had to pick probably because
I'm a massive Ghost Recon fan and I
enjoy the sort of being out in like open
I guess not the city stuff is
interesting but I'll enjoy being it and
the wilderness a little bit your nature
boy I'm a nature boy I play games like
the long dark and I
go off and fall out and rummage in
bushes when people aren't looking and
that's what I want to do in Bolivia
finally let's go to La Paz and act like
a crazy weird US Marine shooting up
cartel people I don't know it seems more
it seems more interesting because of the
videos they've shown and that's kind of
what I'm worried about is that the
division more obscene though it's like
oh the glass is coming off a little bit
if they can do something interesting
with Bolivia mmm that's kind of cool and
like I know the team went there for a
few weeks to talk to locals and figure
stuff out the extent I don't know but I
think if they can tell an interesting
story like I hate to keep beating that
drum but that can actually make me
really interested in that game because I
mean I like metal gear which has a lot
of military esque stuff going on but I
don't really like military stuff why is
that because of you know the other stuff
surrounding it yes devil is in the
detail I guess we'll find it soon enough
let us know what you think what are you
looking forward to more if you had to
pick thankfully you don't but the
division Ghost Recon wildlands let us
know in the comments below which one
you're looking forward to and which one
you hope comes out in 2016